the friendship between our two countries
between britain and germany has become
even more vital
since putin launched his barbaric
onslaught against ukraine bringing war
into our continent i know that britain
and germany share exactly the same sense
of horror and revulsion at the brutality
being unleashed including the
unconscionable bombing of refugees
fleeing their homes this morning
the attack at the train station in
eastern ukraine shows the depths to
which putin's once vaunted army has sunk
at least 39
people killed
and dozens wounded on a train platform
crowded with women and children
it is a war crime
indiscriminately to attack
civilians
and russia's crimes in ukraine will not
go unnoticed or
unpunished
germany and the uk
also share exactly the same conviction
that putin must fail in ukraine which is
why we're working together in the g7 to
toughen our sanctions and target every
pillar of the russian economy in order
to cut off funds from his war machine
the uk and the eu have announced new
sanctions this week
and just today we in the uk have imposed
new asset freezes and travel bans
we will also agree on the importance of
weaning ourselves off dependence on
russian oil and gas and ensuring that
our energy security cannot be threatened
by a rogue state
this is not easy for any of us and i
applaud the seismic decisions taken by
olaf's government to move germany away
from russian
hydrocarbons today we have agreed to
maximize the potential of the north sea
and collaborate on energy security and
on renewables where germany and the uk
lead the way in new technology
we cannot transform our respective
energy systems overnight
but we also know that putin's war will
not end overnight
that's why britain and germany have
joined dozens of allies to supply
ukraine with defensive weapons
last week the uk convened a donor
conference which raised weapons and
equipment for ukraine worth over 1.5
billion pounds or 2.5 million items of
military kit
today i can announce that the uk will
send a further 100 million pounds worth
of high grade military equipment
to ukraine's armed forces
including
more star streak anti-aircraft missiles
which fly at three times the speed of
sound
another 800 anti-tank missiles and
precision munitions
capable of lingering in the sky until
directed to their target
we will also send
more helmets night vision and body armor
on top of the 200 000 pieces of
non-lethal military equipment the uk has
already dispatched
but olaf and i agree
that our two countries and our allies
must go further and provide more help to
ukraine
the europe we knew just six weeks ago
no longer
exists putin's invasion strikes at the
very foundations of the security of our
continent
but his ambition to divide us
has demonstrably failed
on the contrary
he has succeeded in uniting europe and
the whole transatlantic alliance in
support of ukraine
and in strong solidarity with each other
putin has stealed our resolve sharpened
our focus
and he has forced europe to begin
to rearm together to guarantee our
shared security
britain and germany will work together
to ensure that our armed forces are fit
for the future including with our joint
effort to manufacture state-of-the-art
boxer armored vehicles we will hold a
joint cabinet meeting between our two
governments within the next year
our defence ministers will meet before
the nato summit in june and i look
forward to joining you olaf at schloss
elmira for the next g7 summit
we face the new reality created by
putin's invasion
i know that britain and germany will
meet this challenge together as
passionate advocates of democracy and
freedom and both committed friends
of ukraine thank you over to you earlier
thank you